Isaac Newton's second law of motion says
force is equal to mass times
acceleration which means if athletes
want to put in the hard hits it helps to
be fast big and strong collision sports
have always been rough and tough but as
they've become more professional players
have become bigger and stronger which
means their blows have become well but
what impact is this having on collision
sports when it comes to professional
sports winning is everything and in
collision sports like American football
and rugby marginal games can come from
having bigger and stronger athletes
teams are increasingly taking the
players they have and keeping them up to
make them more competitive take rugby
union twenty eight years ago the average
weight of the 1991 World Cup England
squad was ninety four point eight
kilograms in 2019 it's one hundred and
five point nine kilograms that's more
than a ten percent increase
[Music]
jozek anissina plays for England all
right he's a fast guy he plays on the
wing he's also a big guy 115 kg and six
foot three pilots therefore how a rugby
players got so big in 1995 Rugby Union
went from an amateur sport to
professional media moguls like Rupert
Murdoch threw money at broadcast rights
and the sport was to change forever
players had to go from the everyman to
Superman adopting strict fitness regimes
training schedules and diet plans all to
maximize their potential when players
can get a job or earn a much higher
salary as a function of putting on an
extra 10 pounds of muscle you can bet
they're gonna hit the weight room bigger
players can get tired more easily but a
rule change allowing more substitutions
meant players no longer needed to last a
full game the result has been a super
breed of player just take a look at
Jeremy Gus Scott in 1995 compared with
his equivalent Manu Tuilagi in 2019 but
since professionalism there have also
been changes in rugby injuries and some
experts think this may be caused by
players are the higher body mass between
1996 and 2000 immediately after the game
went professional the rate of injuries
among elite Australian players increased
by 57% at Bath University researchers
have been recording rugby injury data
since 2002 they found the rate of
injuries hasn't actually increased since
then but the nature of the injuries has
professor Keith Stokes leads the
research team how long it takes for
players to get back to full training has
increased and we don't really know
whether that's because the
more serious or because the injuries are
being treated differently but what we do
know is that if we talk to some of the
surgeons who carry out surgery under
some of the more serious injuries often
they're more complex these days than
they were before
so that gives us a hint that some of the
collisions that we see create more
structural damage the research team have
also found that the rate of concussions
among players has increased since 2011
and now there is an average of around
one incident of concussion per match the
detection of concussion has improved
dramatically and this might be one of
the reasons why there's been an increase
in concussion of course the other thing
is that the game has changed and things
like an increase in the speed of the
game the amount of time when the ball is
in play and therefore the number of
tackles and the size of those collisions
may also play a role it's not just rugby
American football has been rocked by
reports that an increasing number of
retired NFL players who have suffered
concussions
have developed memory and cognitive
issues a study of deceased NFL players
found that 99 percent of them had a
degenerative brain disease believed to
be caused by repeated blows to the head
the NFL has faced a series of lawsuits
from former players who suffered head
trauma and were demanding compensation
they reached an extremely expensive
settlement and to a certain extent they
have learned a lesson from that or been
forced to in an effort to reduce
concussions the NFL banned helmet to
helmet hips punishing them with a
penalty and sometimes even by suspending
the player across other collision sports
there have been changes around
concussion detection and prevention
these include substitutions for head
injuries while a player is assessed
dr. off the pitch and in the 2019 Rugby
World Cup new rules around high tackles
were brought in which officials say have
led to a 35% reduction in the rate of
concussion these are all positive signs
but a lot of critics would say it's
lipstick on a pig and players are gonna
keep getting hit including their hands
you're never gonna be able to eliminate
that so it does raise questions about
the viability of the sport in the long
run and whether you'll continue to get
athletes who are willing to subject
themselves for this the impact of the
new breed of bigger players goes much
further than what happens on the pitch
behind the scenes it's affecting the
laws of the game and the players safety
as the Superman of collision sports
become ever more powerful balancing
their welfare will become the biggest
challenge
[Music]
you